je me demande pourquoi le docteur a tapé
sur la tête de boxe là alors
il était une fois trois ravissante fille
qui rêvait de devenir flic
malheureusement on les cantonné dans des
besognes inintéressantes
[Musique]
pardon
moins Charlie j'ai décidé de les sortir
de là et j'en ai fait de drôle de dames
[Musique]
on vous les filles c'est Charlie
bonjour C'est Denise ça va les filles
bon écoutez c'est très facile il faut
assurer la protection de Denis poretti
le seul qui puisse témoigner demain
contre Johnny lambraco le chef de la
mafia c'est compris
c'est pas vrai quand même
alors les filles c'est bien compris
personne ne doit rentrer dans cette
chambre alors c'est moi qui prends le
premier tour de garde asseyez-vous
salut les filles et pas de blague
j'accompagne le docteur Tallard pour la
piqûre
et pas vous gagnez
follement amoureuse
allez salut les grosses je m'appelle
Johny lambraco c'est Johnny
le docteur tu
mais il a pas dit que toi ils sont pas
gourde hein si c'était joli
[Applaudissements]
demande pourquoi le docteur elle t'a
fait sur la tête de moche clair alors
une blague
[Musique]